الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في هذا اللقاء
الحصري مع جيمس كليفرلي وزير خارجيه
المملكه المتحده الذي يجلس الينا فور
خروجه من قاعه مجلس الامن بعد القاء كلمه
بلاده
وزير الخارجيه
شكرا جزيلا يسعدنا
مشاركه لقد خرجت مجلس الامن قد تمت خطابا
هاما
المتحدثين الاخره في المجلس ما هي رساله
الاساسيه من هذه الجلسه لمجلس الامن حول
اوكرانيا التي قدمت للعالم
انحاء العالم وكل قاره على وجه الارض كلهم
تحدثوا عن اهميه
على الاحتفاظ بشيء الذي حافظ على سلامته
للعالم ليس فقط حول اوكرانيا ولكن هذا مهم
بل حول هذه المؤسسات التي حافظت على
سلامتنا سمعنا ايضا كلمه
المندوب الروسي
في الاخير وهو الترحيب بما يسمى خطه
السلام الصينيه لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا
وقد رحب بها بينما كان الموقف الماضي
مرارا
انهم
توافق اوكرانيا
الاوكرانيه او القرى او الاستفتاء هل هذه
نقطه تحول من روسيا
بلا شك نحن ننظر الى الوثائق التي قدمها
صينيون وهنالك بعض العناصر الهامه ضمنها
مثل معرضتين باستخدام
المتحده ودائما
ننظر الى هذه الوثيقه بكل جديه وامل
القياده الروسيه اخيرا بدات تدرك الحقيقه
وهي ان العالم يدين تصرفاتهم والعالم يريد
ان تنتهي هذه الحرب ويريد ان يرى اوكرانيا
امنه مع حدودها معترف بها دوليا وامل ان
هذه هي خطوه في الاتجاه المناسب وبكل
صراحه
لازلت غير مقتنع
جاده ما يخص السلام وكلمه الممثل الروسي
حاول ان يصف
نسخه من التاريخ التي لا يعرفها اي انسان
حي
هي المهاجمه او مع العلم ان النساء
والاطفال والرجال الاوكرانيين الذين
يقتلون بالصواريخ والقنابل الروسيه
الجمع العامه
المطالبا
بالانتهاء الفوري للحربي
لسحب روسيا لقواتها من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هل هذا يشمل القرن
كما فهمته
من وجهه نظري
هذه الاعراض الاوكرانيه هي التي يدافعون
عنها وابنائهم واطفالهم هم الذين يقاتلون
والمصطلح مرارا وتكرارا وهو
ضمن الحدود المعترف بها دوليا
واعتقد بان ما يجب ان تدركه روسيا والعالم
ياجماعه
وهذا يخالف المتحده وهذه المشكله الاكبر
للدفاع عنها ولكن ست القرار الاوكرانيين
في الختام هم
هيئه الدوله والحكومه
الدفاع عن نفسها وهم يجبون يتخذوا هذا
القرار حول الشروط التي سيقبلون بها
بريطانيا وفرنسا
ليست
اعضاء في لكن كيف ترى تعليق
كما قلت في كلمه لمجلس الامن
بينما يدرك حالته لغز اوكرانيا لم تحقق
نجاح فسيستخدم كابتن واعد تهديد ولغه
التصعيد وتخويفنا
ومنعنا من لقينا بالشيء الصحيح وهذا جزء
من استراتيجيته ويجب نتركها كما هي عليه
هي تعبير عن الضعف وليس التعبير عن القوه
لا يوجد اي تهديد لروسيا لا احد يتحدث عن
الاضرار بروسيا معنى اقوله هو ان روسيا
يجب ان تتوقف المهاجمه اوكرانيا هنالك
تقارير يتم تداولها حول الصين
وانها تفكر
بتزويد روسيا بالمساعدات الفتاكه اذا ما
حصلت ذلك فما معنى هذا للحرب في اوكرانيا
والعلاقات بين الصين
الحوارات التي خطتها مع الصينيين او وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه
ذكر بانهم
اهميه المتحده في المؤسسه
التصعيد وقد قلت بانني لا اعتقد بانه من
مصلحه الصين ان ننظر له على انها تدعم
نظاما معزولا على المسرح العالمي ولكن ما
اقوله لكافه الدول هو انه لا مصلحه من
التزويد روسيا بمساعده العسكريه فسوف يضر
ذلك بسمعه الدوله وسيكون ذلك هداما واعتقد
بان السلطات الصينيه تدرك ذلك جيدا
بريطانيا هي الثانيه اكبر مانع عسكري
لاوكرانيا بعد الولايات المتحده
لكن تحدثنا عن المؤتمر الفنلندا لدعم
اوكرانيا
الى ان تستعيد اراضيها
وتعيد
النزاهه اراضيها ولكن حلمه تنتهي الحرب او
ينتهي النزاع اوكرانيا امنه
ونستطيع اعادتي بناء تحتيه فهذا سيكون هو
فحوى المؤتمر في يونيو ليضمن التعاون
الدوليه الذين راحوا على الجانب العسكري
يطابق في اعاده بناء اوكرانيا هل هنالك
رقم الوصول اليه
نتعرف على اجمالي اضرار حقن الوقت لديه
سؤال الاخير فيما خصيرا اعترفت ايران
بينها تخصب اليوراني الى مستويات عالي جدا
حوالي تسعين بالمئه وهو مستوى الاسلحه
لديهم العديد من السلوكيات
او الحرس الثوري
فقط الولايات المتحده ضمن قائمه الارهاب
هل تعتقد ابن حان الوقت لبريطانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي لان تفكر في ادراجهم
ضمن قائمه الارهاب خاصه انهم يهددون
المواطنين البريط
اول مشتقين الايرانيين على اراضي بريطانيا
ما شاهدناه
هذه السلوكيات من قبل القياده الايرانيه
وهي غير مقبوله
التسليحيه من الشيعه المسلحه في المنطقه
وتهدد الايرانيين في بريطانيا
ومحاوله تطوير يورانيوم بمستويات الاسلحه
كلها امر غير مقبوله وقد اوضحنا
معارضتنا كلها تصرفات وقد استجبنا عبر
العقوبات وسبل اخرى ونحن دائما نبقي
الخيارات المفتوحه فيما يخصه اي مداخلات
اخرى نستطيع القيام بها ولكن ايران
وقيادتها يجب ان يدرك بان القرارات التي
يتخذونها كلها هدامه جدا
لمصالح ايران
وما نريد ان نراه هو ايران سلميه تعمل
بشكل سلمي مع جيرانها
ولا تهددوا احدا وجمهوريه ناجحه هذا
سيسعدنا جدا ولكن
المتحده شكرا جزيلا على راكون اشكرك جدا
على هذه المقابله شكرا لك